why is a corporate steakhouse so good
I wanted to be dark I want people there
talking about real estate scams and
[ __ ]
I want prostitutes I want tan couples it
just got back from an unfulfilled invoke
a vacation hovering right above misery
silently eaten crab cocktail I want that
I want shellfish towers I want bosses
trying to impress their new hires I want
new hires trying to impress their bosses
I want everybody with their tents and
their dicks out I want collared [ __ ]
shirts I want maitre d's that grab me by
the arm and say is everything okay
I want to canted [ __ ] buckles red
wine I want shrimp scampi and rib eyes
and porterhouses I want [ __ ] aged rib
eyes I want [ __ ] Wagyu kowai kowai gu
Wagyu whatever the [ __ ] it is it's fake
anyway hey seven restaurant servant no
you idiots are paying for it it doesn't
matter
I want [ __ ] slabs of beef and pork
chops and veal chops I want yogi I want
[ __ ] people and shoots sitting around
a table trying to swindle that's what I
love and I wanted to have more than one
location I want to know that the exact
same thing is happening in Dallas in
Chicago and New York at Miami I want to
know that all across the world demons
from hell are dressed to the nines
eating rib eyes I'm deciding if they're
man enough to have a [ __ ] piece of
cheesecake or a Bananas Foster at the
end I want a corporate steakhouse
except Ruth's Chris I hate Ruth's grass
it's up that's a mall steakhouse [ __ ]
you of you eating Ruth's Chris I want
Adele Frisco's or a Smith & Wollensky I
want a paries I want to ocean prime I
want a Capital Grille I want consistency
I want a menu design in a boardroom by
suits I want every location to be the
same I want to know that the sriracha
vinaigrette at the pokeball is the same
everywhere I [ __ ] go and then I don't
have some [ __ ] artist chef gonna ruin
my favorite dish cuz he thinks he's
special you're not follow the [ __ ]
rules the system exists for a reason
Marxist scum but I will
comrade I will argue an appetizer every
now and then off my tab just say this
wasn't really what I thought it would be
but that's what I want it's my favorite
type of restaurant it's always been the
corporate soulless Steakhouse that's a
reality if people don't spend their life
trying to acquire things they will they
they fall into some type of weird quasi
spiritual genocide 'el mania they need
little dumb things to do they're beasts
of burden as jordan peterson said they
need to make enough money to buy
themselves uh mashed potatoes with
lobster on top of it for no goddamn
reason doesn't even taste good doesn't
even taste good but Alan Stillman knew
this you started Fridays and TJ Smith of
olinsky's DP del Frisco knew this who
started though Frisco's whoever the [ __ ]
morton was that fat [ __ ] who started
morton and i don't really love Morton's
but it'll do
I don't like Mastro's out here in LA
it's it's it's I don't like it my point
is a good corporate steakhouse that's
what you tell your woman you're going
you know you're not going to some
[ __ ] open anyone ain't going you know
this little you know 212 c12 table
restaurant and all their food is sourced
from a shut up we're going to a
corporate steakhouse with my father
that's what we're doing cuz we've been
going there for ten years and he's
almost dead make a [ __ ] memory you're
gonna have your petite filet mignon your
Chardonnay you either shut the [ __ ] up
cuz this is a corporate steakhouse and
we deserve this this is the way my
father loves me we go and eat we fill
ourselves with fat salt and sugar and
bread and we feel sick when we leave
doesn't matter we toss in return we do
not sleep well that night because our
body should not be digesting this level
of food but it doesn't matter cuz as
we're tossing and turning everything we
ain't goes into a [ __ ] column of
profit for that corporate Steakhouse and
it
doors and it lives forever and it gives
senators a place to take prostitutes and
it gives older couples a place to just
have that final meal before they decide
they don't want to see each other again
until they lay down in matching burial
plots I just love a Corp I will never
love any restaurant as much as I love a
corporate steakhouse the transience of
the people they'll all be they're all
dying and there'll be another crop of
them moving in the maitre d that
pretends that they care the lonely
people like me sitting at the bar
most of them boozing me just eating and
then the bartender is saying remembering
our names hey thanks for coming Tim yeah
hey thank you thank you I won't go back
to the hotel and blow my brains out
tonight cuz you said thanks for coming
Tim cuz they know how to Lube you up
they know how to make you feel nice cuz
it's a corporate steakhouse
there's not one location there's many
there's accountability there's
structures there's hierarchy things
matter things have to be done the same
way and yes maybe there's not that many
magical moments because you know what
you're gonna get and you expect it so
there's not a lot of magical moments in
those restaurants but guess what the
magics over in this [ __ ] country
you're lucky you're lucky to have
whatever it is that you got there's not
too many magic because nobody's taking
the risks to make the magic because the
risks aren't being rewarded when you
become a brand you can't take risks but
you can deliver a sustainable level of
quality to the people which is all you
should expect you greedy [ __ ] we're an
end stage of an empire and you're
looking for somebody to whip up a
miracle in that kitchen it's not gonna
happen
just get a medium-rare ribeye in a in a
vat of its own fat and a creamed spinach
and keep your mouth shut
stop with the I read a review or this
place looks nice or you know this chef
had an inspiring story she grew up
one leg and now she makes omelets cut it
out
go to the corporate Steakhouse and sit
in the dark corner and eat what you know
you're gonna like maybe hot love was
like the country is over these temples
of consumerism and slabs of beef are
what is left high-end dining is dead it
died in the 90s after 9/11 people took
the tablecloths off the restaurants
people stopped going to French
restaurants they stopped spending three
hours having tasting menus now all the
restaurants in New York that are you
know three-star Michelin restaurants
they all catered a high-end tourist you
know Asian tourists things like that
people have a shitload of money and they
hand you like you know some little jelly
cube and it's like taste like us you
know a carbonated grape fruit and they
go tada and you go no tada [ __ ] you they
hand you a bowl that's just a little sea
urchin foam and a and a great that's
taken out of someone's ass [ __ ] you
I will take my corporate steakhouse
please a nice fat loaf of bread that is
not fresh but it is hot as [ __ ] it's so
hot that I don't remember that it was
here three days ago probably on someone
else's table some other fat slob gnawing
on it I've given up on truly
transcendent dining experiences I've had
many of them but they are over chefs
have become commodities nobody has any
appreciation for art everything sucks
why would food be good that's why you're
all arguing about chick-fil-a shove it
up your ass there's nothing left the
only thing that's left is the corporate
chain steakhouse with the food that
doesn't even make sense do you want crab
on your steak no but pull sure do you
want a lobster crusted steak I don't
even know what that is but yes why
because I have nothing left in my life
crusted with blue cheese and salmon come
I don't care as long as I pay more than
the market price I want to pay over
market for this crust it with nine
things I want the tartare to start the
tuna tartare
and the beef tartare throwing a
shellfish platter give me a tomato
tomato and onion salad and a tomato and
mood surround what do you got a the
autumn bisque some butternut squash soup
calm that into a bowl and serve it to me
for 18 bucks I have nothing left
give me a seafood stuffed mushroom if
you want and then you better litter this
table with beef big slabs assault cured
beef fatty bacon
I want cream spinach and Lyonnaise
potatoes au gratin potatoes mashed
potatoes and you better mash everything
into them beurre blanc sauce butter crab
lobster shellfish stone crab claws you
better take a hunk a rope for cheese and
smash it in those potatoes with your
bare hands because that's what I want I
want a meal that doesn't even make sense
I don't want it to even make sense I
want you to bring something to the table
that I have to explain to someone while
they stare at me what's on your steak
its crusted with lobster and a beurre
blanc sauce and a gorgonzola spinach
souffle I don't know it's a ribeye and
it's in a cage of fried bacon and duck
fat and it's just that's what I want
because that's all that we have left